bad news marvel nerds
many of your favorite characters were
probably stolen from your arch nemesis
it's true dc comics had been churning
out awesome characters since 1934
by the time marvel comics launched in
1939 under their first name
timely comics they were already five
years behind
sure marvel is great but they have quite
a few characters of
questionable origin don't worry dc has a
few marvel rip-offs of its own
which you can learn about in our
companion video characters dc stole from
marvel and gave a new name
but for now here are some of marvel's
greatest characters pitted against their
earlier dc counterparts
the x-men vs the doom patrol it's a
comic about a team of misfits who have
been shunned by society
coming together and learning to use
their powers for good they fight for
acceptance under the leadership of a
brainiac in a wheelchair
they're called the doom patrol and they
were first published in june of 1963
three months before the x-men showed up
coincidence the similarities between the
two teams would grow in march of 1964
when the x-men took on the brotherhood
of evil mutants
meanwhile the doom patrol fought the
brotherhood of evil the similarities
between the two comics were so strong
the dune patrol creator
arnold drake accused stan lee of somehow
stealing his ideas though it's never
been proven
maybe great minds think alike or just
have great mind reading superpowers
black cat versus catwoman originally
known as simply
the cat catwoman appeared in the first
issue of batman published in 1940 she
was originally a cat-themed burglar with
no fancy powers
and today catwoman selena kyle is still
pretty much the same
an agile anti-hero with a romantic
interest in batman
writer marv wolfman basically ripped off
the whole literal cat burglar catwoman
thing when he created felicia hardy the
black cat in 1979.
from the cat-themed morally ambiguous
thief aspects all the way down to her
weird love of spider-man black cat lacks
any kind of
real originality over time black hat got
some vague bad luck powers in a super
suit but felicia black hat hardy still
has her origins as a cheap catwoman
ripoff
bafflation deadpool versus deathstroke
rob liefeld has a bit of a reputation
for not being able to come up with truly
original ideas
when the teen titans fan showed his
first drawings of deadpool to rider
fabian nisiessa in 1991
it was obvious that deadpool wasn't much
more than an unoriginal homage to dc
comics's deathstroke
and niciessa ran with it the terrible
joke expanded to the fact that deadpool
was eventually
named wade wilson after deathstroke's
real name slade wilson
ultimately deadpool was such a silly
character that he took on a life of his
own
becoming a fan favorite and embraced the
most absurd comic adventures ever
written
with a smashed movie from 2016 he's
become a cultural phenomenon
meanwhile deathstroke is still just a
boring assassin obsessed with killing
super teens
but at least he was there first the
vision versus red tornado
you may know vision from avengers age of
ultron but he first appeared in the
comics all the way back in 1968.
the original vision is an evil creation
of ultron designed to destroy the
avengers
and just like in age of ultron vision
ultimately turns against his creator and
becomes a hero as he searches for his
humanity
however this wasn't the first time this
story was told a few years earlier in
1963
a very similar event occurred when a
supervillain designed an android called
red tornado the bot was created to
infiltrate and defeat dc's justice
society of america but ultimately ended
up becoming a hero as well
yes team destroying androids are common
and the two have different powers
but their costumes have just a few too
many similarities to be purely
coincidental
those big belts and enormous collars are
way too ghost to just be accidents
bullseye versus deadshot deadshot first
appears in 1950 as a batman villain
where he's first seen wearing a top hat
while attempting to replace batman as
the hero of gotham
deadshot basically has batman's fighting
skills but brings expert marksmanship to
the table
later in the world of marvel another
street-level hero daredevil would face a
similar fell with bullseye but that
wouldn't happen until 1976.
both deadshot and bullseye are master
marksmen who never miss their targets
i never miss their experts in
hand-to-hand combat have metal body
enhancements and come from abusive
families
the two are basically a couple of sad
sacks with really good aim and that aim
is good enough to keep both of them
working in comics and on screen
but deadshot was first by a long shot
boomerang versus
captain boomerang why marvel comics
would want to mimic dc comics boomerang
tossing bad guy is anyone's guess
because both of them
kind of suck obviously both characters
were born in australia but while canton
boomerang primarily fights the flash
regular boomerang spends a lot of time
fighting marvel's fast talking
spider-man the captain arrived in 1960
while his unranked marvel doppelganger
appeared in 1966.
both use ridiculous augmented boomerangs
that include everything from bombs to
razors to probably bumblebees or
something
and marvel's boomerang even wears a
boomerang on his face like
angry eyebrows just so everyone knows
what he does hey at least captain
boomerang keeps it limited to a really
terrible boomerang print shirt
have we said the word boomerang enough
yet boomerang super adaptoid versus
amazo the idea of an android that could
copy the powers of superheroes was
created by gardner fox and murphy
anderson in 1960. they named him amazo
and he became a pretty big threat to the
justice league of america
six years later stan lee came up with a
strikingly similar idea
sending a robot fell with identical
power copying abilities up against the
avengers
but from where did it come cannot you
guess
captain america granted lee's super
adaptoid looks way cooler than amazon's
weird elf ears and striped pants thing
that's all thanks to jack kirby's
awesome art unfortunately super adaptoid
was just six years too late to be the
original
thanos versus darkseid darkseid is jack
kirby's giant jawed alien overlord of
apocalypse hell bent on seeking out the
anti-life equation and eradicating the
universe of all free will
thanos on the other hand is the giant
jawed overlord of titan
fixated on making death his girlfriend
and subjugating the galaxy
both are super strong telekinetic
teleporters seem to be ageless
and can travel through time and both are
pretty much the most powerful bad guys
in their respective universes
you can't really blame jim starlin for
trying to come up with his own version
of dark side from marvel comics in 1973
because darkseid is one heck of an
awesome villain it doesn't get much
cooler than soul seeking eye lasers but
those eye lasers showed up in 1970
three years prior to marvel's thanos and
his infinity gauntlet even the time gem
can't fix that
thanks for watching subscribe to our
youtube channel to watch more videos of
the one you just saw
and leave us a comment to let us know
which characters you think are the
biggest rip-offs